hey guys now i got a lot of questions
from some of you asking me daniel please
make a video for skinny guys how to gain
weight
or muscle for skinny guys so in the last
10 weeks i worked hard to gain muscle i
went from 74 kilos to over 90 kilos just
so i can explain to you how you can gain
muscle not just talking about it but
actually leading by example so in this
video i'm gonna give you my full
body workout that's gonna help you to go
from skinny to muscle
let's get to it
[Music]
i have a dream
that's all i
i need so i'll take it on
i've made mistakes but mistakes make you
strong
now just very quick if your first time
here on my channel i'm daniel moritz and
welcome to dlm model lifestyle if you
haven't subscribed yet then please do so
you won't miss any of those next videos
now there are three things that you will
need with your workout routine without
it you will fail you will not gain the
muscle that you want and you will be
disappointed in yourself number one
consistency
stay consistent and never skip a workout
number two intensity give your best
effort at every workout your body can
always give you more than you think you
can
and sleep you need enough sleep seven to
eight hours you need enough sleep so
that you can give your body the time it
needs to repair those broken down muscle
tissues alright now with that in mind
let's look at my workout routine that
helped me to gain over 15 kilograms in
just 10 weeks
[Music]
you gotta hit the gym six days a week no
cardio because you don't want to get
skinnier you want to gain weight and
remember to stretch before every workout
you will do all your muscles in three
days why because it will give you enough
time to repair and grow day one will be
abs chest and triceps they too will be
legs and abs day three will be back
biceps and shoulders and then you just
repeat it again so on day four it will
be abs chest and triceps day 5 will be
legs and abs the 6 will be back biceps
and shoulders so each muscle group works
two times a week and then you have one
day a full rest on day one for the abs
for the chest and for the triceps you'll
do the following for the apps one minute
of two up and one down now just remember
if you can't make a full minute it's
fine to rest a few seconds in between
you will get to a full minute when you
are stronger now if you can't make a
full minute it's fine to rest a few
seconds in between you will get to a
full minute when you are stronger next
is one minute of seated ab circles on
each side when you are stronger you will
do it while hanging
third one minute twisted mountain
climbers fourth 30-minute starfish
crunches and then you rest for 30
seconds number five one minute scissors
and then lastly for the abs it's one
minute knee tucks now let's move on to
the chest workouts first normal bench
press now this is important so listen up
set your weight heavy enough so that you
can barely reach 10 repetitions on your
first set you will do a total of four
sets so the aim is to do every set until
muscle failure and after the bench press
you move on to the incline bench press
and next you can choose either you can
do normal dips or you can do lower cable
cross over now these three exercises
you've worked on your lower chest your
middle chest and your upper chest for
the triceps you will do the barbell
tricep extensions while laying down on a
bench and then lastly tricep rope push
downs now this workout should only take
you around one hour if it takes a lot
longer then you're resting too long
between your sets and then to finish
this workout you'll do four normal sets
of traditional push-ups each set until
failure and after this
your body will know that it just had a
killer workout let's move on to day two
day two is legs and abs first up abs
number one jack knives with weights on
your feet and head until failure next up
one minute marching planks number three
scissors with sit-ups you do this for 30
seconds and then
rest for 30 seconds and then you go
again then it's bicycles with weight but
do it slow with your feet up off the
ground do the one side fully before you
do the other side and you do this until
failure next up is weighted ab crunches
and lastly is the hanging leg lifts
until failure and that's it for the app
so let's move on to the legs first up is
squats remember four sets for all the
exercises with barely reaching 10 reps
with the first set after the squats it's
walking lunges
and then a hamstring curls
and after the hamstring curls it's time
for standing cuff raises now a lot of
people also include leg extensions here
but i would not recommend this because
it's really tough it's really hard on
your knees especially if you had a knee
injury so to finish the leg workout i
would usually do the leg press machine
slowly or deadlifts all right let's move
on to day three which is your back your
biceps and shoulders let's start with
the back first you can do wide grip pull
downs and then when you're stronger you
can do normal pull ups when you're done
normal face pulls with the rope and then
hyper extensions for your lower back and
then number four
seated cable rows
after that you'll move on to the biceps
and you're gonna do normal chin ups
first
and if you're not strong enough you can
do normal bicep curls with the curl bar
and then you move to rope bicep curls
for the shoulders you're gonna do
overhead press with dumbbells and then
lastly front and side lateral shoulder
raises and then on day four you're gonna
do the same workout routine as you did
on day one day five the same as day two
and day six the same as day three and on
day seven you're gonna rest now remember
for the weight training exercises you
need to give it your all in every single
set and you need to remember to add the
weights as soon as you get stronger well
if you give it your all and barely reach
10 repetitions with your first set then
you know the weight is fine but as soon
as you can do more than 10 reps then you
know the weight is too light for you and
your muscles need more resistance so you
need to add some weights then you just
do the rest of the sets until failure
but if you can barely reach six
repetitions then it is probably too
heavy for you so then you just have to
adjust the weights to make it a little
bit lighter now don't try to show off to
the people in the gym or try to cheat
the workouts
leave your ego at home when you come to
the gym focus on your form doing every
set the right way now the workout is
just a small part of getting bigger
muscles if you don't eat right you're
not gonna see the gains that you want to
see so in the next video i'm gonna share
my full nutritional plan with you so
if you haven't yet subscribe so you
won't miss that video and that's it guys
cheers